[Music]
how have you been feeling
it's a real nightmare
so what happened
I walked in the front door
I called out for her hello no answer
and then what
[Music]
is there anyone you can think of who
might have done this
a few nights ago
this guy showed up at my house acting
strange strange in what way
we like this I'll go with a boyfriend
I got the friend
I'll take the weirdo
I'm going with the ex-husband unless
suspect well everyone is a suspect
tell me what's going on
[Music]
you gotta think about your future you
can't be a cop forever
can you keep a secret I'm
tell you the secret but first i'm gonna
need you to do something for me
worse now
get out
interesting huh
[Music]